zurück aus der sommerpause und gleich
mitten im wahlkampf nur halt ohne
wahlkampf wenn man ehrlich ist
inzwischen fragt man sich wird die ära
merkel jemals enden viele er ist ja so
viele jüngere zuschauer kennen ja gar
keine andere kanzlerin die wissen gar
nicht dass in deutschland männer
markanter werden durften
ich war noch dabei ist eine verrückte
zeit und auch das sagen wir mal tv-duell
letzten sonntag hatte leider latenten
freundschaftsspielcharakter mit tendenz
zur liebeserklärung je die highlights
für sie kurz zusammengefasst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
a
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mag
ja
[Musik]
das tv-duell letzten sonntag ich finde
es immer schön wenn zwei sich finden
meiner mutter na klar im nachhinein ein
bisschen mehr attacke ein bisschen mehr
aggressivität vom schulz wäre schon
prima gewesen andererseits kamen seine
themen
ja so gut wie gar nicht dran bei dieser
mündlichen abi prüfung und er hat auch
weiß ich wie sie es gesehen habe ich
finde er hat es nicht wirklich schlecht
gemacht vor allem dieser eine satz vom
schulz der hat mich wirklich nicht
nachdenklich gemacht jeden satz von
richtig oder falsch gibt es einen ort
dort treffen wir uns
oh ja es gibt einen ort jenseits von
richtig oder falsch
und dieser ort heißt würselen meine
damen und herren es ist halt es ist
nicht leicht
als ein gespräch aus dem alten kalender
abgeschrieben er ist aber wirklich nicht
leicht natürlich hat die spd nach all
den jahren das ja so ähnlich wie hunde
jahre ein glaubwürdigkeitsproblem
vielleicht ist es mit der spd wie beim
hsv
wir müssen auch mal absteigen um wieder
ja um wieder zu sich zu finden und die
frau merkel die hat natürlich eiskalt
ihren amtsbonus ausgespielt es ist
wahnsinn wenn die frau alles kennt dazu
habe ich heute mit dem französischen
präsidenten im akkord telefoniert ich
werde mit dem russischen präsidenten
sprechen mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten herrn erdogan mit dem
chinesischen präsidenten sprechen
natürlich mit japan und südkorea und
wird morgen auch mit 100 touristen frau
merkel
[Applaus]
sehen sie alles schon fälle von
speichern und schuld sein so ich habe
gestern versucht meine frau zu erreichen
aber die ist nicht rangegangen über eine
stunde haben die über migration und
flüchtlinge geredet herzlichen
glückwunsch afd gewonnen beim duell ohne
dabei zu sein
gerade mal fünf minuten haben die über
soziale gerechtigkeit geredet und nur
mal so ein unverbindlicher tipp von mir
wenn man flüchtlingen ratschläge gibt
zum thema deutsche sprache ruhig auch
mal auf den eigenen satzbau achten daher
sage ich nur wer jetzt hier schon
mehrere jahre ist und sich wirklich die
deutsche sprache gelernt hat da sollte
man richtig sprechen tun ja ihr neuestes
plakat lernen sie sich erst mal richtig
deutsch cdu und ich finde was
deutschland geht die kanzlerin müsste
das eigentlich beherrschen nach 27
jahren im westen oder naja
[Applaus]
das darf man wohl erwarten
auch die andere seite muss sich
integrieren gut klar einen klaren sieger
hatte dieses pseudo duell leider nicht
letztes wochenende und das merkt man
auch so ein bisschen an den fragen die
danach von entfernten zuschauern im netz
gestellt wurden
die meistgestellte frage des gestrigen
abends war wie alt ist franz müntefering
ich musste raten 100
ja das war die nummer eins zuschauer
frage nach dem duell auf platz 2
natürlich wann fängt endlich der tatort
an
zumindest im moment sieht's also nicht
gut aus für die sozialdemokraten mendes
freundlich ausdrücken wollen oder kommt
da doch noch spannung auf dieser
ard-experte ist er skeptisch
tut mir leid die spd hat für mich keine
realistischen chancen mehr wenn sie sich
nicht vollständig verändert immer ein
schlechtes zeichen wenn clowns dir sagen
was du falsch machst du kriegst diese
merkel halt nicht zu packen die soll
stück seife und in wirklichkeit das
wissen sie gibt es ja sogar zwei angela
merkels die eine ist sowie eine
arbeitsteilung die eine die gute merkel
die besetzte themen cloud in dem gegner
die besetzt hier benutzung scheinen und
macht dann in der realität was völlig
anderes
die gute merke sie erzählt beim duell
was von zusammenhalt in einer sozial
gerechten gesellschaft dabei verdienen
40 prozent der beschäftigten bei uns
real weniger als vor 20 jahren
ein fünftel der deutschen arbeitet
prekär jeder dritte deutsche besitzt
quasi nix also außer schulden jetzt und
wenn es auf cdu plakaten im ganzen land
heißt für ein deutschland in dem wir gut
und gerne leben muss ich schon mal
nachhaken wertete es wir die über zwei
millionen armen kinder hier ein original
spot von uns wirklich nur minimal
bearbeitet
in welchem deutschland was du einmal
leben
wird es dass deutschland sein dass uns
am herzen
[Musik]
da in deutschland soll ein land sein in
dem wir alle gut und gerne leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
spd arbeitet auch mit dem millionen
tatsächlich werden mal nachgeguckt
tatsächlich hat die bundeskanzlerin in
diesem wahlkampf bis jetzt nur eine
wirklich knallharte konkrete aussage
gemacht das wissen sie und zwar neulich
in der bunten der sache zitat ich
verstand für die kartoffeln immer selbst
mit einem kartoffelstampf und nicht mit
der poliermaschine so bleiben in der
konsistenz immer noch kleine stückchen
übrig ist dass ihre die kanzlerin stammt
selber wer soll die frau noch aufhalten
frage ich sie ja